Hello friends, welcome to my channel.
Today I will share what I learned about
the VDB nodes in geometry nodes in
Blender.0. There's to be honest a bunch
of nodes to learn also they are very
useful. So I think it's worth to learn
them and if you have dived into these
nodes before you will find that blend
developer platform for their articles
about these nodes they introduced or
what is the VDB there is some concept
about grid and what's so and some usable
nodes node system how to use them like
there are VDB modeling If you are
interested, I will put the link below.
And uh today what I will share is based
on my own experience and uh I will
introduce them like following the
sequence of the nodes in blend software
and first let's talk about the concept
of VDB in blend. So you can see there
are monkey head here and there are cubes
here. Uh I just uh like instance the
cubes on the VDB
like there is a cube here and I turn it
turn it into VDB
and I instanced like many cubes on it.
So this will make you make it very
easier for you to understand what is
like the grid like there are many grids
grids and and you can also understand
that by this image provided by brand
website. You can see there are small
cubes. There are the grid and the grid
contains information like density like
velocity temperature and information
about uh flame like that.
Uh there is much small
concept is the work. The grid is made of
work and if you want to make like a very
detailed effect you need to turn the
grid into work by some nodes. I will
introduce the nodes in this uh video. So
you can see here the cubes means it's a
grid contains information. If we want to
define the number of a grid that you
need to have XYZ
three dimensions like index node we
define the number of index in a geometry
we use like integer one two 0 one two
three uh but in VDB grid we will need to
define like 0 0
uh 0 0 one like that.
So, so XYZ
uh three directions. So, after that I
listed some nodes here like
there there there is a sequence like in
blend
you can see uh there is a volume here
and there is read sample write operation
and primitive. So I follow this sequence
and list all of the nodes here. And you
can see here there are some nodes that
isn't listed in the sequence.
There are like somewhere in the node
system but they also related to the DDB
to the grid. So I listed them here. So I
will follow the sequence here to
introduce them one by one.
So first we can see the primitive
uh the volume cube. If we preview it you
can see let me check missing output. We
need out output here.
So we preview that it's just a VDB cube.
It contains information of density and
the background.
like I changed the density,
change the background. It didn't work.
Uh I don't know why it should work.
So you can tweak this if you want it.
It's very simple.
And next we
uh we will learn this this node there
like change the match to grid.
So uh I will call a match here. It's a
monkey. So you can see there are SDF
grid and the density grid and the
volume. Uh the volume you must be very
familiar with that like u
it has existed for a long time. So if we
link the monkey head to here and preview
it, it turned it it into a monkey head.
There's a volume here.
So uh I disconnected this and
the three nodes are new. So first I will
check a match to SDF grid.
So you can see
if I turn the work down.
uh maybe it's not very easy for you to
see that
I like bandwidth five bandwidth more
bandwidth you can see a monkey head
inside
uh because SDF is like based on the like
there is a distance
this is
the SDF grid grid is like uh especially
for modeling
and You can see this and if I link to
point
you can see this.
So here I will introduce uh a node like
turn the grid into
mesh to so I use this grid to mesh to
for for better understanding of this
nodes. So this is like based on the so I
preview this you can see there are many
points.
So uh the face has more points and like
on the back of the head there are less
points. So this points to SD SDF grid it
mean it turned turned every point here
into grade.
So if I preview it, you can see
every point is turned into grid.
And if I connect the match to SF grid,
so it will turn this mesh into grid. You
can trick the work if you want.
Uh so SDF grid is especially for
modeling
and here is matched to uh density grade.
You can link it and preview it.
Uh it will be like this. It's not for
modeling.
So the function of this SDF grid and the
density grade is very different. The
density grid contains the information of
density. So these are the four nodes. Uh
we will use them uh in the following
introduction. And next we can see like
get that name the read the raid
information and the work index
like if I
build a volume cube here it uh it has a
density information.
So I can use the that name grid
here and I preview it. So you can see a
volume and if you check the grid you can
see nothing because we didn't uh define
what uh what attribute we want to get.
So here we choose density. So we take
the density and we get the volume.
So
uh and uh let's check this
input a group input
preview it.
So you can see uh there is a flame here.
So if I connect it to volume and
preview it. So it can preview the
density
velocity because the velocity has XYZ3
value. So it correspond with the RGB. So
it has color and the flame and the
shadow and temperature
like this. It will get the uh attribute
inside the VDB and put it into a grid.
And next is the grid information. So
with this these nodes you can uh get the
information of the grid like if you
connect a grid here you can get the
transport information and the background
value.
So transform is a metric background
value is like the minimum value of this
uh this uh like the minim minimum value
in the parade. If you put if you have
the density value so the minimum value
of the density like for this the minimum
density is zero
and here we can get to the work index
it is similar to this as I introduced in
the beginning so it has
three value three dimension
So next we will go to sample. Sample is
a very important node sample array.
And here I use group input.
Uh maybe not maybe just
volume cube
and I get the
attribute of preview this. I need to
first preview this attribute of density.
uh then I can like uh reccast this
density on a geometry. So
uh we can use the
sample
sample. So we have like sampled the
density uh we can't see anything because
we have know we need a geometry to like
uh do it.
So but we need
yeah
and the geometry maybe
I think the grid is good.
So grid will make it bigger.
And uh
here here is the grid and here is the uh
sampled attribute. So you can see it
didn't work because we connected the the
wrong sort
to grade.
So you can see the information here.
So it means it don't have enough
subdivision. So
here I will give it a bigger value like
30.
You can see
if we I open to 100. You can see inside
it's one outside is zero and like in
between there are like a numbers like
this.
So I need to turn off the
text.
So this is sample. So with uh this with
this method you can like do a lot of
things. After we sample that value we
can
like we can have
uh like this this four nodes. So from
this chart you can see that gradient
will turn a scalar field into a vector
and the curl in the vorticity like
it it will turn like the velocity into
divergence is like a describe uh field a
field expansion or compression and that
is about smoothness. Yes.
So you can try them and here like uh I
will show you how to use them. Like I
think this volume cube is not very
suitable for demonstration. Here I will
use grid input.
If I use this I can choose like
like here many many.
So I can see where it's here and
you can see this
uh this is the faz density I think.
Yeah. Yeah. The fing density. So here we
have this
uh like black and white.
So,
so here here is a gradient
a grid gradient. We can connect the grid
here. It will turn it into gradient as I
talk about talking about like this.
This is the gradient.
If you spread a particles here, it it
can move the particles to make like some
kind of effect like my last tutorial.
And uh if you want to like the Ling you
can try that what what effect it will
make. You just connect here and then
connect it to the grid. It will be like
this. So you can try and
and let me check if you want to use
these two nodes you need like a
threedimensional value. So here we have
velocity.
It's just crashed and I started again.
So we disconnect this and turn into
vector and we choose the velocity. So we
have a like a 3D dimension attributes.
So connected to like first we check the
row effect like
into vector
row effect is like like this.
No, here and it's a rect like this.
So, uh
normally we don't want the row effect.
We want it like much like like much
complicated effect.
So, we turn into a turn the velocity
into a work vorticity effect and change
that you can have this. It's like uh you
can try that spread some points in this
space and you can see the effect
and if you can you want to check this
and al
yeah
if you can check this effect greater
divergence you can connect here
and uh like sample it need to be a float
connect here it's like this uh so you
can try to use them what effect you will
have.
So they are used here the four nodes.
Okay.
And here we have sample
grade index and adapt grade.
So this uh this nodes
add back to grade it means it can like
add uh two attribute field two attribute
grade together to make a new grade like
if here I will connect this to here.
No
into float preview
into density. So I have a grid here and
like you can connect the velocity here.
Yeah, it will be like this.
If you like uh let's try add a curl
here.
It will be like this.
So,
and let's try
if we add a gradient here, it'll be like
like this. So, so
you can just try.
Okay, that's great. It didn't crash. So,
you can try to use them to make
different effects. Just try. After that,
we have a right. So store name attribute
set background and set transform.
So let's talk about these three nodes.
Uh these three are very simple.
Delete them. Delete them.
So we have volume two here.
And that's
name the grid. So we have a grid like I
preview this
we can do the density and we have a cube
here.
Uh and we use output nodes
output here. And let's check if we are
Yeah. Delete this.
Let's check if if we want to output the
grid.
Output grid like we can see nothing. We
can't output the grid.
So this this node here
you link the G here and uh you have VB
here. So it it can turn the like uh G
the G because the G is like the
combination
combination of the attribute it's not
VDB. So it can turn this attribute into
uh VDB and output it. So then you can
render this
uh render this VB. So you can't render
the grid. So this is where we use this
spawn in the grid
and for the set background.
Let me check if
Turn the density lower and set the
background
like it didn't work. So sometimes it
worked. It's a uh yeah
it's a plane and connect.
So here here [snorts]
I get the density.
So here
so this is the uh like smoke simulation.
Uh so the background is like the minimum
uh I get the density attribute for this
grade. So this background background is
like uh the minimum value of this
density like and now it's zero. So the
transparent part is zero. So if I turn
it into one so normally all of them
needed to be like
it should be a four cube but I don't
know why it's like this but it's a you
can understand you can understand this
it's a minimum value in the density if
you increase it it's it's like over to
like 26 six
and set G transform is it's like much
easier to understand. So if you link it
it it will bigger like this. I don't
know why I didn't change anything. So
there is a trans transform here we talk
about this it like
here it will output the transform and
the background value
the g for. So background value is set by
this node and transform value is set by
this node. So we can
combine metric
or combine
transform use these two nodes or other
nodes
uh you can make calculations.
So if you
yeah if you tweak the numbers it will
correspond with your action.
So rotation scale anything you can you
can just change there
very simple
and here we go to operation. This is
about uh normally about modeling.
So we have
like uh let me copy that.
So G to mesh and volume to mesh. This is
very easy to understand like
a volume cube. If I connect this to this
here is a volume cube. If I turn the
volume into mesh, it will be like this.
And
like if you only have the density,
you can't turn the density into density
grad into mesh. So we need a G to mesh
here.
You turn into a mesh. So they are
similar but used in uh different
circumstance.
And then
uh we will go to SDF for B
and there are these nodes.
So you can see SDF grid is especially
designed for modeling.
As we talked about
that we have a tube here like blender
use this to show you how to use that. So
I will rec recreate this uh this
scenario
we transform this cube this cylinder
like this. Yeah.
So I use the mask to SDF grid. It must
be STF grid. Connect them. You can see
copy it here. Connect them.
There is a ceiling inside.
So
then I use the read to me
that
so the cube
is like this.
So we need a lower work like 0.1.
Yeah, that's better.
And for the cylinder. Yeah, smaller
works. Yeah, that's better.
So now we need to use SDF green boolean
to like combine them together. It has
the three mode intersection, union and
the difference. So I connected. This is
the difference.
Like if I change the position of the
cylinder.
Yeah, you can see this is the bully
difference and the union
negative. Yeah, this is the union. This
is the intersection.
So you can try that by yourself.
And there are some nodes here
this way. So this one is a simple
offset.
You can see I will use union uniform.
Yeah.
Yeah. Offset
this expansion.
H. Yeah. This is the contraction.
So
after that we talk about these nodes.
They're all about the smooth but
different effect. You can link the first
grid fillet.
You can see
it is like this. If we try the
G location, it will be like this. So you
can decide which one you prefer on
different occasion.
They are very different
here. Like this.
Yeah. here like this. Yeah,
very simple.
And then we have the field to grid and
works.
So field to grid I think.
Uh
okay I deleted
there is no system.
H my blend crash because I lost that
system. So I will rebuild this system.
So I will build a system here to
density. Yeah.
And I use a field to
the read here. So it has nothing.
So this node like we can use some
attribute like a noise or other
attribute. You can define some certain
attribute to affect the grid system. So
here I
here I use noise
connect this
and I think I need to use a ramp here.
Let's check it.
So I know I think it's not very easy to
see that
as we know grid is created by attribute
inside. So I think we can use node here.
Uh we can use the multiply
add the attribute. It will be like this.
Uh so let's check before
before it's like a cube and after we use
noise it's like this. So this is what
this node is for.
You can use like other attribute to
affect the g system.
So for work li and prune. So as we
talked about in the beginning, the so is
like very uh like a rough level and the
work is very detailed detailed
uh level and the smallest element is. So
you want to make like a many very
detailed effect you need to use the work
to vulize the grade to release the full
performance.
So like this
you edit that it will be like this. And
I change it the scale. So it looks like
this. And Peru is like the
uh like the invert invert work slides.
If you yeah I have connected them. If
you turn the value into one so it return
into the uh the mode. If I turn to zero,
it turn into the vualized mode.
So sometimes you want to save computer
performance, you can use the nodes to do
something. And I think I finished all
the introduction. I think the VDB nodes
updated in Blender 5.0
is like a very big update. There's a lot
of nodes to learn.
So, I think this tutorial is helpful and
hope you like it. So, this is all about
today's tutorial. Thank you for
watching. Bye-bye.